is the bubble about to burst for bitcoin
it lost half its value friday other
cryptocurrencies are dealing in the red
and world markets are in decline what
does that say about the global economy
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i am
hashim mahal
bitcoin the mother of all
cryptocurrencies has lost half its value
in just a few hours it reached an
all-time high of more than 65 thousand
dollars last year but on friday it
dropped below 35 000
for the first time in months
and it's not just bitcoin some of the
biggest names in the blockchain have
been trading in red some blame russia's
central bank which proposed on friday a
ban on the trade and mining of crypto
currencies a ban by china last september
had a similar effect but a u.s federal
reserve decision to hike interest rates
was already having an impact before the
russian
announcement
let's take a quick look at bitcoin's
short history
it was created in 2008 by an unknown
person or group of people under the name
of satoshi nakamoto it began circulating
a year later as an open source software
which means anyone could access its
blueprint and make their own type of
coin
the digital currency was intended for
people to send money online and avoid
the global banking system but value
fluctuated sharply as people
experimented on how to use it
now bitcoin can be used to buy anything
from property electric cars and even
drugs and weapons without leaving a
trace
let's bring in our guests in london naim
aslam chief market analyst at ava trade
in singapore janet capron director of
kaepernick and author of chomping at the
bitcoin
past present and future bitcoin in china
from dublin professor brian lucy
professor of international finance and
commodities at trinity business school
welcome to the program
naim do we know exactly what's behind
the cryptocurrency pool
thanks for having me there are a number
of factors that are adversely
influencing the prices two of them
you've mentioned
but the most important one is the risk
of sentiment among investors which
triggered the big sell-off now how the
sell-off really happened that triggered
that was triggered by the federal
reserve when federal reserve started to
adopt to to to give more hawkish stance
to the market because last year everyone
was anticipating three interest rate
hikes and fed wants to increase interest
rate to control inflation
and bitcoin is a natural hedge to
inflation we know throughout the world
inflation is getting out of control now
the federal reserve bank which is the
central bank in america wants to control
that inflation was to contr
reduce the supply of dollar in the
system hence we are seeing this little
bit of a retreat in the price i wanted
to emphasize one important thing over
here sure with respect to bitcoin
halving its prices from where they are
now because last year we saw the price
action going all the way to 69 000. now
34 000 to 35 000 that's nothing new for
this beast
bitcoin is known for its volatility
especially during the month of january
over the last 10 years we have seen
plenty of volatility for bitcoin
genon is it
because of the fact that bitcoins are
our cryptocurrencies are the best hedge
against inflation the moment reports
started to circulate about the federal
reserve starting to move forward past
the
uh uh
past the covey decisions particularly
when it comes to stimulus and
uh tackling inflation there's been a
panic reaction in the global stock
market and by definition that extended
to the cryptocurrency itself and this
explains why we they're tumbling
yes i completely agree i think
you know there bitcoin is very volatile
obviously as we know and and
the reactions tend to be a lot greater
uh in terms of reacting to market news
or a sentiment out there and i think you
know what we're seeing now is definitely
a retreat but as as mentioned you know
this is nothing new for cryptocurrency
whether that be bitcoin ethereum or any
of the other many alt coins that are out
there is this volatility is there
it
is most likely you know on the
historical basis a temporary uh
i guess setback you would call it for
bitcoin uh you know we've seen this in
the past where it's lost 40 50 of its
value and then creeped right back up so
it could just be the trend that we've
always seen in january and that
volatility uh but who knows what holds
the future for bitcoin
brian but at the same time when you have
the dual of the cryptocurrencies bitcoin
suffering this massive slide could that
be an indication that this is not just
one of those old cycles of and all high
and then uh
a dive this could be an indication that
there's something completely or
intrinsically wrong with the very
philosophy of bitcoins
or cryptocurrencies
yeah i mean the problem with cryptos is
like any other assets once you know a
professor or a market analyst says the
top is in or the bottom is in you know
they will be made to look foolish so
is this
is is this the
start of an irrevocable decline in
crypto's value uh i don't know i don't
think so uh i think cryptocurrencies
have a role and will continue to play a
role and therefore even though there is
an argument that they have no
fundamental intrinsic value most people
accept them as a form of money
regardless of what they're doing with us
then it will have a value as as a form
of money
the
difficulty as the other speakers have
mentioned is that the very nature of
this
beast is such that it is incredibly
volatile and it's it's exposed to
volatility
across a very wide range more so perhaps
in other assets it's exposed to
geopolitical volatility uh it's exposed
to economic volatility it's exposed to
sentiment volatility it's exposed to
regulatory volatility and all of these
are
moving in a bit of a perfect storm
against crypto and indeed some other
assets at the moment
in particular the regulatory one is the
one which i think is the biggest bayer
case as it were for uh for for cryptos
the very success of cryptocurrencies
showing that there is a a market for a
big uh for a uh anonymous digital uh
monetary transactions uh product
is one that central banks will not let
go past they will and they are moving
towards central bank digital currencies
which are not crypto and don't have the
um the main advantage of crypto is that
it's uh it it's not traceable it can be
used therefore as you mentioned for you
know good or ill as it were in terms of
uh purchasing central bank digital
currencies to be really effective would
have to require uh we would not be
decentralized it would not be anonymous
okay but there is a market out there
most people most retail invest
people won't really care that much
business might care a little bit more
about the central bank having
uh the ability to look into their into
their systems but you know they can do
that anyway through regulatory and tax
oversight all right
naim
the decisions by the russians the
chinese to ban
cryptocurrency transactions is i is it
justified in a financial world order
you know i'm going to answer that
question from a slightly different angle
if you're a crypto believer and then you
are ready to buy
bitcoin at a price of a 69 000 per
bitcoin
why would you not buy it at current
price which is more than 50 discount
regulatory
stance has always been tough we have we
had over 15 different occasions when
china sort of announced crypto banning
or moving towards that now russia also
is doing that and even the republic of
pakistan was also thinking of banning
cryptos over there but i think for
traders and for investors especially
wall street banks the most important
aspect is
what is the u.s stands towards cryptos
now we all know what blackrock is the
biggest asset management company in the
world
blackrock was the primary dealer
and the primary advisor to the u.s
during the 2009 financial crisis
during the corporate prices
now blackrock is a major stakeholder in
a crypto mining firms i.e bitcoin mining
that really sets the narrative where
bitcoin is really going to be going
and in our research and what we believe
is that this is the last time perhaps
we're going to see a retracement where
the price will be trading below 50 000
because the next bull rally whenever
that will happen no one can predict and
i'd be wrong if i will say that yes we
know
but that bull run
whenever that will happen that will take
the prices of well above 100 000 in
maybe perhaps near 150 to 200. okay the
correction or the plunge is going to
bring the prices back to 50 and 60 and
at that time you will call that a crash
all right then the law of 50 it's going
to happen okay zen and the reason why i
brought the issue of the
clam down by countries like russia and
and china is that weeks ago
the head of the u.s
of america securities and exchange
commission
gary
gensler said the following when he was
talking about cryptocurrencies it's a
market
rife with fraud scams
and abuse
leaving many people to believe that this
could be the beginning of the end of a
of a thriving business
yeah i mean i think you could say the
same thing about any market around the
world whether that be you know u.s stock
markets the u.s dollar et cetera i mean
there's there's plenty of examples in
every market of abuse and and fraud and
and everything else that uh gensler was
kind of pointing at so i think it's you
know pointing out crypto certainly it's
happening more in the crypto space
because it's a much newer market
but you know fundamentally i think
things have gone a bit too far in the
u.s i mean you have uh i mean
too far to be stopped at this point i
mean you have coinbase as an example
yeah it's a multi-billion dollar company
that's listed on the stock exchange you
have many other mining companies that
have already been listed or lining up
for specs or ipos so i think you know if
the government really wanted to move
around this and was really anti-crypto
they would have had to done it earlier
because i think you know putting the
genie back in the bottle at this point
would be quite difficult for any of the
regulators in the u.s
brian is it fair to say that just the
very nature of cryptocurrency the fact
that it's digitally encrypted based on
blockchain not controlled by any central
authority
it has been widely
uh
described for a political reason as a
threat to the financial stability and
therefore we're seeing those
those dips
yeah the um
the history of money and history money
in the united states in particular is
littered with private money and this is
what crypto is
and private banks
private money creating banks
and in the 1930s 1840s 1850s we saw
these come and go
with
gleeful abandon the united states also
has in its political dna if it chooses
to reach into it a fairly significant
history of if it wants to and i'm not
sure if the present mood is such that it
would uh clamping down very hard and
very fast on extremely large
corporations that it deems to be
in in the consumer and in national
self-interest
the other problem that crypto is exposed
to however
is one that we hinted on earlier on
which is about
sentiment and
the reality is that bitcoin is an
incredibly dirty currency
it's
it's a small asset in global terms and
yet it's
you know the way in which it is produced
in mind where whether it's in
turkmenistan or in anywhere else
tends to naturally go towards the
cheapest kind of energy production which
at the moment is still typically going
to be heavily carbon intensive
uh
ways and
bitcoin uses more electricity than
medium-sized countries you know bitcoin
is the netherlands bitcoin is you know
mexico and um
you know from a global warming
perspective people get very head up
about
you know clamping down on travel and
worrying about whether they should
switch to a hybrid
you know getting rid of crypto which i'm
not advocating
would knock a large chunk of the problem
right out the window now as
antophogenic global warming continues as
that becomes an existential threat
towards countries that's going to
make the
make it very least to switch towards
cleaner cryptos and there are cleaner
ways of of both mining and using cryptos
become uh become a regulatory must i
think all right now naim you've you've
listened to what brian has just been
saying now this fallout is it manageable
or what do you think cryptocurrency
should be doing in the near future to
win the hearts and minds of the people
and of the regulatory systems all over
the world
sure so i just wanted to
make some comments
what's been said earlier
fiat currency or fiat money isn't really
green at all as well look at the amount
of paper which has been circulated inc
and everything which comes with it
secondly
with respect to the bitcoin mining now
over 55 to nearly 60 percent of that uh
money is being actually used uh the
mining is done through renewable energy
number three if you believe in metaverse
which is the next future web 3-0
then this currency is the future digital
currency is the future number four
now
actually regulators within europe and
i'm speaking of germany that the
economic engine of the eurozone has
allowed hedge funds to have allocation
up to 10 in cryptocurrencies once the
dust will settle and we come out of this
particular
uh storm that we are currently facing
with respect to bitcoin
you will see
a barrage of headlines coming out and
mentioning
corporates hedge funds institutions
family officers buying cryptos at a
major discount it is in their favor what
is happening in the media which is
driving the prices lower but make no
mistake fiat money
isn't really that um
friendly to uh
environmentally friendly as well i have
to disagree go ahead go ahead yeah yes
brian go ahead
first of all you know the amount of
money like money in our pockets as a
percentage
of global money is infinitesimally small
so yeah you're absolutely right that's
uh you know
big paperworks and and stamping out
coins is not particularly
environmentally friendly
but the reality is especially with covet
you know we are moving towards a digital
environment where money exists only as
electrons
secondly the amount of transactions and
the amount of
activity and the size of the entire
crypto market
is still incredibly small by comparison
to the global monetary environment and
therefore
if you don't mind
let's just give let's just give brian a
few seconds to continue people you know
people say oh you know
crypto is just as dirty as gold but the
gold market is several times larger
so on a you know per dollar transaction
basis crypto is a dirty currency now
what you said about digital currencies
is absolutely correct i think that is
where we are going
you know and i was a central banker for
a brief period um
you know i'm not speaking as a central
banker anymore i haven't been for a long
time but central banks and governments
will not allow private money
in the end the very success and the
undoubted success of cryptocurrencies
and all of the issues you mentioned such
as metaverse
and the you know digital natives that
you know our next generations are
governments will step in and they will
create central bank digital currencies
which will then
uh you know per force
either by force or by by usage
regulate our
relegates bitcoin and others to
uh what it probably really is which is a
speculative asset class rather than an
actual monetary asset
right well just for the sake of moving
forward i'll i i'll have to pick up from
where you both of you agree which is
basically that digital currency is going
to become a reality uh uh
in the future and now zelen in the
meantime this is a new speculative
investment and this explains why people
are looking forward to see more history
and data to be able to see how they can
predict in the near future i mean to be
able to do that what do we have to
implement are we talking about
regulations first of all
traceability of the of of the
transactions themselves for this to be
adopted by the international
institutions
well i think i think it's really
fundamentally if people believe in it if
it if it has value to the mass
population i mean obviously now there's
a
there's a certain subset of the
population being both retail and
institutions that believe that bitcoin
is worth the 35 odd thousand dollars at
the moment and at one point was worth
sixty thousand dollars uh until your
your mother your father your your close
family believe in that as well then
we're always going to struggle with this
volatility i mean that's one of the
reasons that you know the us dollar is
is is so fungible and everybody accepts
it that it's accepted as a medium of
exchange and so you know the volatility
around the exchange rate all the other
fx tends to go with the us dollar as a
reference point um in in terms of
traceability you know when we look at
cryptocurrencies in general there's some
very sophisticated players out there
that are able to track pretty much where
any of the bitcoins or any of the other
cryptocurrencies have been or are going
i
you know the days of this being
completely anonymous or even
pseudo-anonymous are are pretty much
called i mean most of this is fairly
traceable at this point name why is it
taking government so long to cope with
this new reality that cryptocurrencies
have to become part of the daily
financial transactions
i think it's
if a government's to react and
historically looking at these particular
histories of money and then how many
different fiat or currencies existed it
actually takes quite some time for
regulators to get a complete handle on
this thing and if you look at especially
in the years
i think the fact that we have companies
like coinbase and a number of other
companies being listed on the u.s
exchanges and then this training trend
is highly likely to continue especially
when wall street giants like goldman
sachs jp morgan city bank and all of
these banks are actually offering this
particular asset class whether that's a
speculative whether that's considered as
a store for value
it really stems the case for the
cryptocurrencies to flourish from here
onwards
brian should we
there is another argument which is
basically why don't we
focus this time more on stable coins as
a bridge between the
somehow stable assets like the dollar
and the gold and the cryptocurrencies
and when we build that trust it would
pave the way for cryptocurrency to
further thrive in the future and people
to build trust trust with it
so
the the problem with with stable coins
is not all stable coins are are stable
um there's different kinds of stable
coins
the the big one we all know about is
tether and there are you know persistent
questions about the actual backing
for tether the way in which tether
operates and its relationship with some
of the larger players this is well
documented uh there are other crypto
stable coins out there that are backed
by commodities and of course we know
that there are commodity cycles and
super cycles
if you have a cryptocurrency which is
fully transparently 100 backed by uh you
know let's say uh euros
it's a problem in search of a solution
why not just use the euros directly
instead of going through an intermediary
um
so i don't think stable coins are are
the solution okay they may help
some people to mitigate their the
volatility um
but
they're not you know they're not the
solution to
uh you know why cryptos are not being
adopted the cryptos would be adopted
widespread when you can pay your taxes
in them it's not about going to get a
coffee okay we've seen a market
experiment where where in
el salvador um you know
crypto libertarian
fans have said oh you know let people
use crypto and you know you'll see
fiat currencies will be abolished and
and they haven't all right
xanan now when you look at most of the
governments including the us are
thinking about the post code with
realities in terms of how to tackle
inflation and also to uh
how to move beyond the stimulus packages
that was translated immediately with
this
urge by most of the investors to look
for new equities they're more attracted
to high tech companies and this explains
why somehow they are really staying away
from risk and when it comes to risk this
explains why the cryptocurrency is
paying the price what should the
cryptocurrency industry itself do to be
appealing to the investors
well i think you know and to a certain
extent the fiscal policy and monetary
policy of the us government is is
outside of the control of everybody
besides the us government and the
regulators i i think you know what we've
seen in the crypto industry over the
past two years has been relatively
impressive impressive for two
significant areas first of all uh
there's a lot more professionals that
are getting into it i mean here in
singapore uh constantly we're hearing of
bankers that are working for large
financial institutions and shifting over
to [ __ ] crypto so it is
professionalizing quite a bit and
that's the affecting the second part
which is the solutions that they're
bringing to market i mean a lot of these
are are developed by industry
professionals who have a very clear idea
of what's happening in the market so i
think the sophistication of the
platforms that are coming out and and
the cryptocurrencies that are coming out
is is quite a bit different than we saw
in the last run up in maybe 2017 2018 so
i think it kind of signals a new market
for crypto and a new level of maturity
for the industry but at the same time it
is as you mentioned a very high risk
asset so along with you know tech stocks
and other other asset classes we've seen
them take a beating over the past couple
of months as the as the government in
the us has gotten more hawkish certainly
with fiscal and monetary policy
it will be interesting to see how the
cryptocurrency will be able to manage
this dramatic slide naim
aslam and xenon capron brian leslie i
really appreciate your insight and
looking forward to talking to you in the
near future
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story for
and the entire team here in doha bye for
now
[Music]